من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح ينضم
الينا الصحفي اشرف ابو عمرا اشرف ما اخر
المعلومات المتوفره لديك حول المستجدات
الميدانيه نعم المستجدات الميدانيه
متسارعه في المحافظه الوسطى حيث قبل قليل
اغارت الطائرات الاسرائيليه على وسط مخيم
المغازي للاجئين الفلسطينيين حيث قصفت
الطائرات الحربيه على ما يبدو مربعا سكنيا
بالقرب من مدرسه الاعداديه للب حيث وردت
معلومات هنا من قبل شهود عيان لنا بان
الطائرات الحربيه تقصف في هذه المنطقه
بالاضافه ذلك من تواجدنا هنا في مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى شاهدنا قبل قليل قصفا مدفعيا
اسرائيليا في منطقه شرق المصدر بالقرب من
منطقه الزوايده القريبه من شارع صلاح
الدين حيث هناك السنه دخان وانفجارات
كبيره قد حدثت في هذه المنطقه ناجمه عن
اطلاق المدفعيه الاسرائيليه عدد من
قذائفها باتجاه اهداف حتى الان لم تعرف
بعد ولكن من منطقه غرب الزوايده وبالتحديد
الشارع الفاصل الواصل ما بين مخيم
النصيرات ومدينه دير البلح جاءت الى
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى عده اصابات بالاضافه
الى شهيدين جراء قصف مدفعي اسرائيلي اما
منطقه شارع العشرين بالقرب من مخيم
النصيرات هناك حدثت ايضا اشتباكات مسلحه
عنيفه جدا ما بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
والقوات الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
النصيرات وسط القطاع هذه المنطقه تشهد منذ
مساء الامس وحتى الان عمليات قصف متواصله
من قبل المدفعيه الاسرائيليه ومن قبل
القوات التي تحاول التقدم باتجاه مخيم
النصيرات من المحور الشرقي لها ولكن حتى
هذه اللحظات لم تستطع الدخول كثيرا في
داخل عمق مخيم النصيرات نظرا لاصوات
الاشتباكات التي تسمع وهي ناجمه عن تصدي
المقاومه الفلسطينيه لهذا التقدم اما شرق
مخيم البريج وهي المنطقه التي تشهد عمليات
عسكريه واسعه للجيش الاسرائيلي وكما صدرت
المقاومه الفلسطينيه عده بيانات لها
وفيديوهات تثبت اشتباكات ضاريه وكبيره جدا
وجها لوجه مع القوات الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
مخيم البريج حتى الان لم تستطع سيارات
الاسعاف الوصول اليهم لنقلهم هنا لمستشفى
شهداء الاقصى نتحدث عن اربع ايام من
الانقطاع
التام للاتصالات بالاضافه الى الانترنت
هناك عدم انعدام كامل في عمليه التواصل ما
بين المواطنين وهذا يعيق تحرك سيارات
الاسعاف والطواقم الطبيه في هذه المناطق
التي تشهد عمليات عسكريه في هذه الاوقات
شكرا جزيلا لك من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في
دير البلح الصح في اشرف ابو عمرا